>>> Moments ago, Lizzo broke her silence on the
lawsuit filed against her by three former dancers
who claim they were subject today a hostile
work environment and harassment. The claim
naming her production company and captain of her
dance team. It says the dancers were exposed to
outings where nudity and sexuality were a focal
point. It alleges that lizzo called out one of
the plaintiffs for her weight gain after accusing
the dancer of not being committed to her role.
Lizzo is known, of course, for her uplifting
messages and advocacy for body positivity.
>> I am not gonna be able to please everybody
with my outward appearance. Someone's always
gonna have a critique, negativity to say about
me. All that matters is what I think about it.
>> Now, after what had been a notably lengthy
silence, she responded to the lawsuit on
[8:37:41 AM]
responded to the lawsuit on Instagram writing, in
part, the sensationalized studies are coming from
former employees who publicly admitted they were
told their behavior on tour was inappropriate and
unprofessional. I take my music and performances
seriously because at the end of the day I only
want to put out the best art that represents me
and my fans with passion comes hard work and high
standards. Joining us now are the three dancers,
crystal Williams, Ariana Davis and Noel Rodriguez
along with their attorney. Crystal, the response
that you have to the response from lizzo after the
silence for an extended period time?
>>
Yeah, I want to say that reading it just kinda
furthered my, like, disappointment in regards
to the situation, just because the facts
are the facts. What we experienced and what
we witnessed is absolutely what happened.
There is nothing sensationalized about it.
[8:38:41 AM]
about it. So all that I can hope is that
people focus more so on the facts rather
than the court of public opinion.
>> Ariana, at what point did you
realize that what you were experiencing,
allegedly experienced, was not normal?
>> I -- it's hard to answer that question
because, as this was my first professional job,
I was told by the dance captain and, you know,
just -- it's this thing in the dance industry
that you have to, you know, shut up and, you know,
take whatever you get and just be grateful for
whatever crumbs you get as a dancer. So a lot of
things that were going on, it took me a really
long time to figure out that it was wrong. It
took me, actually, until leaving the camp that
I figured out that everything that was -- went
on was bad, because I just chalked it up
to, lizzo might abdiva or this is just the
[8:39:44 AM]
abdiva or this is just the industry,
this is what we go through. I
think that I had ink wlings. Like, I would be
on the phone with my mom all day and be, like,
just complaining about this disrespect and
the treatment and the humiliation. I mean,
me personally, looking at the response from
lizzo, was so disheartening, because she was
there. She was there. And to fix your hand
to write on a piece of paper that you don't
believe -- that you discredit everything
we're saying is incredibly frustrating.
The facts are the facts, like crystal said. Was
I pressured to touch a nude performer? Yes. Was I
brought into a private meeting where I was kind
of interrogated about my personal matters and
ended up having to share very personal, personal
things about myself, regarding my weight? Yes.
[8:40:44 AM]
Yes. I mean, the list goes on. Were we
pressured to do an excruciatingly long
rehearsal that turned into a reaudition for the
job that we already booked because, apparently,
we weren't doing enough? Yes, that is true.
During that reaudition process, was I under the
impression if I left the stage, I would be fired?
Yes. Did I, unfortunately, go to the bathroom on
myself on one stage, because I was so terrified?
Yes. There is -- in a court of law, I don't
know -- I'm not a lawyer. I don't know anything.
But I know if you ask someone to tell the truth,
these things will come out of her mouth. If you
have to say yes or no to these questions, she
has to say yes, because they are true. There was
multiple witnesses. And I -- I don't appreciate
the discredit of our feelings and
[8:41:47 AM]
discredit of our feelings
and our experiences and our
traumas.
>>
Understood. Joelle, you allege that lizzo intended
to hit you at one point after you -- sorry. Know
am. Intended to hit you one point after you
resigned. Do you really think she was going to
resort or could resort to physical violence?
>> Yeah, I do. I do. I mean, the facts
of that were that she actually balled up her fist
like this to me. She started cracking her knuckles
and she was, like, you're so f-ing lucky
that, basically, I am not gonna hit you.
And that, you know, I was in shock watching
her do that and cracking her knuckles and
acting as if she was going to come after me.
For a second I was, like, I don't think she's
gonna do that. That's not gonna happen.
The fact that one of her dancers -- all of
us were present. All of the dancers were
present for every -- mostly all of these
[8:42:47 AM]
for every -- mostly all of
these allegations. And in
that meeting that we had where she got
physical and was about to assault me,
her best friend, who is also one of the dancers,
had to jump out of the couch and physically hold
her back from coming and hitting me. So,
yes, I do believe that if she wasn't held
back by that dancer, she would have hit me.
>> What you describe there, there is clearly
not only do you believe you have witnesses, but
potentially other people you would think would
want to be a part of a lawsuit. To some degree,
I would direct that your way, in terms of do you
believe more people will join? Do you believe
that there are other individuals who worked
with these three women, who experienced the same
things, that would like to join this lawsuit,
or sue on their own account in the future?
>> 100%. People have already come on social
media to support our clients.
People have already reached out
[8:43:48 AM]
People have already reached out to my
office through social media. 100%. I
believe more people will come forward,
if not here where we are in Los Angeles,
but in new York, and we received
other calls, and inquiries from around